there's this clip going around on the
internet where guy asked him did he fail
this season uh do you get the promotion
every year no right so every year you
work is a failure no every year you work
you work towards something towards a
goal which is to get a promotion to be
able to take care of your parents you
work towards a go is not a failure it's
steps to success I love that Giannis did
that because there's so many comps to it
right now A lot of people are realizing
what athletes are dealing with because
now everyone's putting themselves out
there and they're getting commented
about everything about everything about
everything one bad night and everyone's
got all sorts of things to say every one
of us in this room right now we have bad
days but it's hidden it's a very
interesting human psychology
conversation I love that that Viral clip
is going because I hope it helps people